john
blazing by everyone loves to use the
left hand for the slam
great play here by john wall with the
left hand bringing the thunder over be
easy it's not easy right there that's a
tough play there by john
malcolm brogman milwaukee bucks
o'connell falls down and wall throws it
down with the left hand
if it was the other way around that
would be a charge on him
instead wall gets away with it hammers
it down
that's a status non-call mike
muhammad from butler too strong out the
pass
wide open westbrook tucking the hammer
and pulling the trigger the timberwolves
18 to 12. adams to westbrook
touchdown oklahoma city
good anticipation by wall he's going to
easily
beat jokic down the court his first
field goal is an
emphatic one a great job by john wall
anticipating just shooting the gap there
and
it's off to the races and man
that's taking it out on something or
someone the power and the physicality
of john wall from the lakers there's one
of those unforced turnovers you're
talking about
here's wall exploding to the rim
the lefty hammer from john wall with all
the elevation he needed
you can go over the scattering point and
say don't allow him to get to his left
hand it doesn't matter
he's that good i remember coaches say
don't don't let him do
you try to take the suit off and stop
him shaking your head because he got to
his left hand this is what he does
every night
you do not have to get two technicals to
be ejected whoa
at the other end at the buzzer what a
half for washington
wall you see the clock winding down
launches
and scores five blocks
wizards throw it away west matthews with
wall trailing and he blocks it
beale chases it down and saves it the
nba
and for john wall lurking cara nothing
is safe
get it right buck the best shot blackie
point guard
well proclaimed
225 to play first quarter walt
tries and the left-handed slam over
lopez
take a look at our honda drive of the
game
that was a little bit of everything
right there from john wall when he gets
downhill going left with a full head of
steam
it's intercepted by kent baseball
blocked from behind by wall here's
porter the other way
shovel for beale beale back to marquis
for an open look
and drains another long shot italian
john is just straight
toying with dudes now i mean just
waiting
mike scott in the game he had 10 points
at halftime off the bench
again quartet inside score the field
goal
he'll go to the line on a brilliant
no-look pass from wall
better here the pass or the catch you be
the judge the pass
was brilliant but how about that catch
by march to save it
corral it put it in and then finish to
the contact
yeah nice little note look there
underneath knocked away by gortat on a
terrific play
wall between his legs behind his back
goes off the glass and scores
tremendous play by john wall and john
wall how about these moves
wow i mean since then
thunders kept it quiet
westbrook exploded
look at this
well russell has the three now force
fields
and he's fouled on the run-out and
they're gonna count the buckets
get the foul to done and listen to this
crowd
he didn't get the call only westbrook
can do this
as we've seen him so many times just put
so much effort in one play
and has the energy to do that
got nine in the quarter 11 for the game
i think 11 this half
i'm not mistaken that's blocked by wall
john wall up blocks it against the
backboard they got the right call
they've signaled wizards ball
how about that plastering the backboard
now the self-proclaimed best shot
blocking point guard in nba history
adds another one to his list good
defense sadaransky in the game for dc
wall no look past the quartet for the
flush
great pass beautiful shot
and the wizards 11 fast break points
on an 11-nothing run
five seconds to go don't leave a whole
lot of time for the hawks
and they score this bucket here we go
westbrook
squaring up with the three-point line he
scores
indeed russell
finishes with 30 points the thunder with
13 makes from three this thing turned in
to a prize fight
that went the absolute limit michael
of the thunders nine wins
in the month of december eight of them
have been within two possessions
that's picked off by wall with a nice
steal two on one with a great pass to
beale
is that through the lake that was
through the legs we've had some
outstanding highlights in transition
transition a reward for working hard on
the defensive end
left-handed between the legs there phil
grant kind of stole that pass away from
raymond
the rim is crying with his sixth
consecutive
double-double and one of the loudest
pockets you'll see
this season felton busts loose
westbrook checked by snell he pulls up
he fires he scores
with 4.7 seconds remaining
about a quick three raymond phelps went
over got the ball
russ with tony snell left a whole lot of
room
and from distance
russell westbrook knocks it down
to tie the ball game the thunder has
trailed wizards turn it over there's six
nice fake and that's blocked from behind
by wall
coming out of nowhere porter alley-oop
for beale
saves it to ubra and slams it home
coming up on three minutes to play wall
drives
finish with a left hand to make a
statement
paul often takes control in these
situations he does so
here 218 to play
george with the double team randall wild
shot westbrook clears and here he goes
got two defenders on him and he goes
right past caldwell's hope
what a finish what a play by the mvp
wow
had a foul to give just look at the pace
that he plays with lulzy to sleep and
then all of a sudden
changes gears and finishes that's bad
defense but that's great often
14 points on seven of 11 shooting
bledsoe drives knocked away scott got it
to wall john spins in the lane gives it
up beautiful pass
and the finish by mike scott the ball
which is push pace
find a teammate that can give his team
the best opportunity to score
boom right in the hands of mike scott on
the weak side make yourself available to
john wall just have your hands up
he's going to give it to you where you
can finish
thunder has a timeout westbrook driving
to the riming scores
you don't need a jump shot you don't
need a three you need exactly
what russell westbrook did and that was
a lot of contact but the official hasn't
been given that
so you don't worry about that you worry
about trying to make that layup
as russ just puts his head down goes
into the body
of the shot blocker howling anderson
you talk about crashing the boards folks
and talk about passing a bucket
that's a crash rush letting you know
that
he's in the house and everybody else is
just on the guest list right now
the last time these teams played it was
triple overtime russ
has struggled all night big great
three-point shooting team we tell you
that they're 30th in the league which is
last
he
keep an eye on westbrook how he gets
down in here changes direction gets it
and then he sees the shot blocker but
i'm going up over the top here
the [ __ ] here jackson randall
and he'll go on the floor westbrook for
the win
get it westbrook scores it
to drag the dagger into sacramento's
heart
here we go
and it's just a big shot and you know he
knew he had no time
other than it was enough time to catch
and shoot he released it
almost like he knew the time was about
to expire
let me tell you something hit that back
of that rim and didn't even move the net
great call by the thunder to isolate the
floor
spread it and leave westbrook singled up
with garrett temple
or second time this season that's a
little miscommunication as they play
more
minutes together he'll know that he's
one who's got lots of great luck wow
man filthy this is tough to do as linda
is at the rim
brewer with another steal over the top
rush in a two-on watch
at the free throw line to help keep the
thunder afloat in a wicked shooting
quarter for the kings
wow westbrook lost everybody somebody
want to pick up their jock strap out
there
this is thundering up just making things
happen russ that's a nice play there man
i'll tell you
six to shoot rubio the bounce
go bear turns it over oh russell
westbrook
goes airborne those first two attempts
faces out and makes them pay
no guerra inside missed it blocked by
wall
wall lawson sets up for three hits it
been waiting for this all game john wall
with the highlight block
and then it's off to the races ty lawson
you said it buck he's been hot from
beyond the three-point arc
all night long you know rock solid first
two games of this playoff
pair of seven for tens if i'm not
mistaken he had the same uh
same stats both games how about that
block derozan thinks he's by him
it's by kelly ubra but he's not by john
wall
great help on the back side the defense
tonight
markedly better for the wizards
gets it back shot clock resets
as wall delivers from the corner putting
it down
nasty play by wall
john wall has been sensational in this
series ready for this game with the
start
this one got him out of their seats my
goodness
look at that attack he throws it right
down with that left hand elevates he is
pumped up early in this game valentina's
coming over
he was with the celtics banging in those
threes remember that that one game was
just outrageous
great passing
it's a little pick and roll but watch
what he does pulls up for the shot sees
mohimi
that's an area that 2018. if you want to
watch an nba game in 2018 that's
look at that john wall
our honda drive of the game john wall
loves to finish with that left hand
i guess the ball the ball doesn't lie
westbrook finds the trailer in noel with
the stuff
the thunder back up to a 19-point lead
sun's calling timeout four minutes into
this third quarter
thunder trying to get a win number one
in case you need it
oh great defense forcing the turnover on
williams
the live voice
wow jumped off the trampoline
and how about the loud play by terence
ferguson
how many times have we seen russell
westbrook doing this play
to terence ferguson and russ man i'll
tell you what he was
up there as you can tell that's all of
the emotion
inside vucovic knocked away the wizards
have it again
here's wall over the timeline wall
behind his back
lays it up and in it's a one-point game
spectacular play by john wall
those haven't scored a point now in over
three minutes and another turnover this
time by howard
amino the other side but there's brad
there's john wall as you said
self-proclaimed best defensive guard in
history but we've got a foul call
watch aminu john wall is going to put
this ball up on the glass
watch dwight howard coming in over the
top
wall on hard gets by him goes right
no call wall down court
behind his back lays it up and in
with the foul what a play by john wall
and this is all he could do well i think
john said don't play with me
a honda drive of the game james ennis
behind the back to avoid the defender
then
taking the contact excellent timing
and just a flailing james ennis that
gets the foul
it's a pretty good play for mr this is
good defense once again by the thunder
they're just starting to take control of
this quarter what a pass
westbrook slipped it in in the pocket of
adams knew exactly what to
do with it hustle kyle kuzma to get that
board
wizards pick it off again it's troy
brown with a pass to wall
who goes back to decker fabulous move
by the wizards in transition
two seconds for wall backs up for the
long jumper
got it at the buzzer
john wall slaps five with the fans on
the court
everything going right for wall and the
wizards here in the
balls missed six shots in 20 attempts
and a block by wall sends it into the
crowd in the front row
will chamberlain well it's easy to under
appreciate
the career of world chamberlain it's not
hard
to appreciate paul george as westbrook
has his triple double it comes on a play
like this here at this moment
in the ball game line to win defensive
player of the year as well
oh look at her
leonard missed the follow russell with
the loose ball
they can get the tie westbrook on the
drive
got it
five points in a row for the dragon
that counts a triple on the run for
westbrook to end the third quarter
russell westbrook to the basketball
one second left to play russell
westbrook
with his biggest basket as a rocket
open court turning on the jets at the
three-point line
and laying it in before holmes could
block it
huge huge shot for westbrook he went by
buddy hill like he was standing in mud
and that's what westbrook brings to the
rocket
meanwhile portland after carmelo anthony
was fouled by hardin
got just one score in its first 10
possessions
ariza rejected by westbrook what a
recovery by russell westbrook
and his effectiveness on the defensive
end
that's the athleticism look at the ups
and you have to be competitive to be
successful at this level but russ is
probably the most competitive by hardin
to westbrook
who climbed the ladder and punched it
now here is james horton's lob over the
top to westbrook look at how high
westbrook gets up
off the floor and the hang time it takes
to wait for the pass wow that was a
great pass
the other way inside of a minute to go
in the third
langford defending in space between the
rings comes around a jeff green screen
goes on the lot to westbrook
who flies down the left baseline and
slams it home with a right hand
yep running three for waters on a two
for one try for the celtics and that
goes
rondo controlling it and his pocket
picked by covington
covington's so good at that one of the
top steels man in the league
and westbrook on the live from hardin
to go james harden finding his running
buddy
russell westbrook on the lob houston 10
points off
la's eight turnovers tonight and a
five-point lead
green just missed the layup
rondo touch pass to caldwell pope he's
on the drive and he's met at the rim